BRAD TEMPLETON: All right,
why don't we go ahead.
Welcome.
This is Authors at Google.
I'm Brad Templeton from Google
X. What we have today are two
of the most respected writers
of science fiction,
particularly hard science
fiction, I think, we have in
the field, Gregory Benford
and Larry Niven.
Both of these men have been
nominated for, and won,
science fiction's top awards,
the Hugo award
and the Nebula Award.
You've probably read Larry's
books in what's called the
Known Space series, including
works like "Ringworld" and
"Neutron Star." Gregory, I
think, got his first big hit
with "Timescape," although I
know you had other things.
But that won you the
Nebula Award.
Gregory's also a professor
of physics at UC Irvine.
And he is also now a biotech
entrepreneur, having worked to
found a company called
Genescient, whose goal is to
stop human beings from
dying like flies.
And he may be able to answer
some questions
about that, as well.
They have a new book that's just
come out this week called
"Bowl of Heaven," that we see
on the screen, and they're
going to talk about that.
And there's many other things in
their careers that I'm sure
will be interesting to us.
And then we'll have Q&A.
GREGORY BENFORD: Thank you.
LARRY NIVEN: Quite a crowd.
GREGORY BENFORD: Nice crowd.
See, and they're very orderly
and everything.
This is a talk mostly about--
of course, what everybody in
the room probably knows--
about the idea of what were
called Big Dumb Objects.
We'll get to that.
But here's "Ringworld,"
Larry's.
Remember "Ringworld"?
It's been 42 years.
LARRY NIVEN: It has been.
We celebrated the 40th
anniversary by running a
reprint and a lot
of publicity.
"Ringworld." Let me talk
about the Big Dumb--
[FEEDBACK]
LARRY NIVEN: OK.
Trying that again.
Let me talk about the Big
Dumb Object concept.
I like David Gerrold's phrase,
which was the Enormous Big
Thing, as the plot
line for a story.
It sounds like nothing
happens.
The key to nothing happening was
not our first discovery;
it was all the marvelous, empty
cities found by Conan
the Cimmerian and Tarzan
of the Apes.
Empty cities can be explored
without things
happening all at once.
You can discover what's
going on.
You can find the interesting
things.
You can get attacked
by the interesting
monsters, one at a time.
You drop Conan the Cimmerian
into New York City, he'll be
bewildered for a long time.
GREGORY BENFORD: Mostly
by the New Yorkers.
LARRY NIVEN: So I wrote
"Ringworld" as
nearly emptied of rulers.
Nobody's running it.
People came to be running it
in later volumes, but for
"Ringworld," you don't even
see who built it.
It's just there, and
you can explore--
well, with sky cycles
about one quarter of the
distance across the width, is
how much got explored
in "Ringworld."
And that was my point.
It's just too big to look at.
Notice, however, it's 93 million
miles in radius, 600
million miles in
circumference.
It's the Earth's orbit,
approximately.
And it's entirely filled
by a habitat.
I made it a million miles
across, but that's arbitrary.
You could make it two, or
half, whatever you like.
It's so big that air leaking
over the rim walls, which
stand 1,000 miles high
at either edge--
air leaking over the rim walls
doesn't rob you of your
atmosphere in any decent time.
It can last millions of
years doing that.
GREGORY BENFORD:
Yeah, that's--
LARRY NIVEN: Sorry.
GREGORY BENFORD: And that's
what makes it dumb.
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah.
Well, it is perhaps
a dumb idea but it
gives you better visuals.
And I was after the visuals.
GREGORY BENFORD: It's dumb in
the sense of being struck dumb
in awe at the prospect of even
exploring the thing.
You see, it's too big to cross,
but it's not too big to
write about.
And the whole point--
next slide--
is that this book, this whole
idea, descends also from
something probably all of you
know, the Dyson Sphere idea.
Because Freeman Dyson just said,
look, a really advanced
civilization will use all the
energy that's getting wasted
into the night sky
by its star.
And it'll absorb it, and
use it for something.
And then, of course because of
the laws of physics, it'll
re-radiate it into
the infrared.
So the thing to look for, and
the reason this is published
as a scientific paper, not
just as speculation, is
unexplained infrared objects
that are very compact
in the night sky.
By the way, I'll get to a recent
grant given to look for
exactly that, in a little
bit, at UC Berkeley.
LARRY NIVEN: The point of the
idea is that you can find it.
You don't have to wait for
people who want to talk to us.
Super-powered beings who have
been civilized for a billion
years are not likely to
want to talk to us.
But if they've built Dyson
Spheres, you can find them.
GREGORY BENFORD: The galaxy
might easily be full of
entities that don't really,
especially want to talk to us.
For example, New Yorkers.
So the whole idea comes also
from later ideas that people
have manifested.
Like, if it's in the stage of
being built, it's going to
take awhile to build this.
You could get a Dyson Swarm of
solar-powered satellites and
habitats like this.
LARRY NIVEN: Next
GREGORY BENFORD: Or--
and you could put them in
various kinds of orbits that
would make it look like,
what's called a Dyson
Bubble, like this.
And there are all kinds of ideas
about how to maintain
these structures, and therefore,
over time, you
would use up the resource.
LARRY NIVEN: Next.
GREGORY BENFORD: And so, toward
the end it might even
look like this.
And therefore, this is actually
an object we could
look at using Kepler and another
satellites, and the
recently finished infrared
search called WISE.
That's an acronym, as usual.
Next slide.
And therefore, a grant was just
gotten by Geoff Marcy
over at UC Berkeley that will
use the Lick Observatory,
right over there on the hills,
to look for Dyson Spheres,
using the best data we now have
accumulated from those
two missions, the WISE
and the Kepler.
And you could actually, if you
care to, you could put this in
as a public charity actually.
If you go to that address, you
can make a donation to the
Dyson Sphere search.
BRAD TEMPLETON: Why are you
looking at me, in particular?
GREGORY BENFORD: Well,
because you're a
large infrared object.
Walked right into
that one, Brad.
BRAD TEMPLETON: I'm a skilled
engineer, but my job is
pushing a next button
on a slide.
GREGORY BENFORD: Exactly so.
So you see, this is an
ongoing project.
I mean, I've known Geoff
Marcy a long time.
And I knew he was interested
in this, and while we were
writing the novel, it
all came to mind.
Now it actually, coincidentally,
just in time
to come out with our book, is
the news that he got the
grant, $200,000.
You'd be amazed what you can do
for such a small amount of
money at Google.
Next.
Here's the definition of
a Big Dumb Object.
I'll give you a minute
to read it.
OK, time's up, and--
this is Google, right?
No, go back to it.
Go back to the last slide.
LARRY NIVEN: Their minutes are
still 60 seconds longer.
GREGORY BENFORD: This is from
Peter Nichols, a noted SF
critic, who said, basically
it's an interesting--
as Larry pointed out-- it's a
great narrative structure
because nobody bothers your
protagonist while he staggers
around, trying to understand
what's going on.
And that actually is useful
in "Ringworld" and Conan.
Because Conan, apparently,
doesn't seem to
be that bright anyway.
LARRY NIVEN: But it is
the amateurish--
the semi-amateurish
way to write.
I knew I was young and foolish
and needed more skills.
when I wrote "Ringworld."
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
This, by the way,
is from an essay
that's on my own website.
With Peter's permission, I put
the whole essay up about
re-reading hard science
fiction.
It's a lot of thoughts
about it.
You can go to GregoryBenford.com
and go down
in the blog--
or somewhere on that site, among
the articles, I think,
and it's got his essay.
OK, time's up.
Next slide.
And of course, if you've been
around in this field long
enough, you know that there
were the ONeill fashion.
The big fashion of the 1970's
was writing about these
cylinder colonies that we would
put in space and have
habitats, and so forth.
Gerry O'Neill pursued this in
great detail, and showed that
you could do it.
And it was a good idea.
And then, as typical in many--
much of the evolution of science
fiction, it fades away
and you get another idea.
I can remember when I started
reading SF in the 1950's, the
big idea was telepathy.
Whatever happened to
that idea, right?
Next.
LARRY NIVEN: Robert Silverberg
happened to that idea.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yes, see,
Robert Silverberg.
Although Connie Willis is
writing a telepathy novel now,
she told me.
Next.
BRAD TEMPLETON: Pre-cognition
sort of failed too as a theme.
I wonder why they didn't
see that coming.
GREGORY BENFORD: That's good.
And then "Rendezvous
with Rama"--
Arthur C. Clarke.
Big alien artifact, suspiciously
like an O'Neill
colony, comes into the solar
system, and takes off for
parts unknown.
And you explore it.
And again, there appears
to be nobody in charge.
There's some aliens
crawling around.
They turned out to be
maintenance features.
Nobody knows what the
hell this was
for, and then it goes.
That's the thing is you try to
leave the wizard behind the
curtain, if you possibly can.
Next.
And this is ours.
That's the Bowl of Heaven.
That little bright point,
that's the star.
The big blue and white zone is
the main habitable zone, but
you actually could live under
that rather tan-colored
section, which is mirrors.
Not entirely mirrors,
but mostly.
LARRY NIVEN: Notice
something here.
If you start with a Dyson
Sphere, and work within the
laws of physics as we know them,
you're bound to wind up
using just the equator, and
spinning it for gravity.
You spin it for gravity.
The equator is the only thing
that will hold an atmosphere,
because from the higher levels,
atmosphere will flow down.
In this object, you still have
to pocket the atmosphere to
avoid losing it.
But the half-Dyson Sphere
doesn't quite work.
You wind up with a Ringworld
with a wok-shaped lid, and a
hole in the lid, if you're
going to make it move.
GREGORY BENFORD: Tell
them the title.
LARRY NIVEN: The title
is "Bowl of Heaven."
GREGORY BENFORD: But our first
title was "Wokworld." Somehow
it didn't seem to quite--
LARRY NIVEN: And then I borrowed
a term, which I had
seen 48 years ago, for a cartoon
done for a set of
cartoons done about
the Ringworld.
One of them laid out the plot
line in a few hundred words,
and called it "Cupworld." You've
got a half of a Dyson
Sphere, space ports in the
handle, and night and day
provided by orbiting tea bags.
GREGORY BENFORD: And somehow
that didn't get written up.
I don't know why.
LARRY NIVEN: "Cupworld" wasn't
good enough. "Bowl of Heaven"
works just fine.
GREGORY BENFORD: And you'll
notice there are other
features here.
Those mirrors in a great
fraction of the bowl reflect
back on to a tiny spot on the
surface of the rapidly
rotating star.
As you know, stellar
rotation gives you
strong magnetic fields.
It's true on our [? sun. ?]
Very high magnetic fields.
And this concentrated energy
ignites a flare which turns
into a jet.
It bulges out and then the
magnetic fields that are
entrained focus the jet so it
streams through the knothole.
The whole system is
going somewhere.
LARRY NIVEN: The star is
accelerating and the Bowl
follows because of
gravity, and some
fancy magnetic fields.
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
And here I was again able to
moonlight because I've
published several dozen papers
on the dynamics, the
stability, and origin of the
jets that come from the
accretion disks around both
stars and black holes.
And I published them in
"Astrophysical Journal," gone
to a lot of conferences, and
then decided to use that
expertise, because jets form
naturally an astonishingly
large number of times.
We now have seen hundreds of
jets coming from black hole
regions around the universe.
And there are dozens around
black holes and
stars in our galaxy.
So the jet and the Bowl all make
an integrated system that
is a transport system that
people could live in.
Mysteries ensue.
LARRY NIVEN: It's a Big Smart
Object because it needs
constant maintenance.
You don't dare lose
your civilization.
You lose your civilization,
you've lost your habitat.
It'll spin out of control, it'll
impact the sun, it'll go
straight to hell.
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
Yet much of the land in the
Bowl of Heaven is natural.
It's a natural habitat.
It has enormous parks.
They utterly dominate.
It's not just a big
New York City.
And so you have to wonder, why
was this built, who built it,
and what's its point?
And obviously the point is that
it's going somewhere,
unlike "Ringworld."
Interesting plot point, right?
All of this is the pre-thinking
before you write
the first line.
And in the first line someone is
waking up-- a human, a guy,
a biologist--
on a starship that's headed
for a planet called Glory,
because the watch officers--
almost all the expedition
is in the deep
sleep, and fairly cold--
the watch officers suddenly saw
appear off to the side,
this thing, because they
had overtaken it.
Because you couldn't
see it from behind.
The star was blocked.
And the jet wasn't quite
luminous enough to register at
a distance.
And the thing is about
a quarter of a
light year away anyway.
LARRY NIVEN: What Greg hasn't
said is, this thing is
accelerating directly away
from Earth, with the same
target as the spaceship that
contains our protagonists.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yes.
LARRY NIVEN: They were
bound to catch up.
The Bowl wasn't big enough to
see until they got closer.
And of course they're moving
through the flare.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
Which has some implications
about what's been happening to
the starship, which we'll let
you discover when you read the
Google discounted book.
So all of this is the beginning
of the plot.
Notice how much thinking you've
got to do before you
can write the first page.
It really does help to plan.
LARRY NIVEN: Until you write
the first page, it's all
recreation.
Collaborations don't become work
until you start writing.
Until then it's just fun.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
Until then it's an excuse
to meet in a bar.
LARRY NIVEN: I have spent a
whole afternoon walking with a
guy named Michael [? Crew ?],
carving out a novel as we
walked around the hills
of Berkeley.
We get back to the house, and we
find out that neither of us
actually wants to write.
GREGORY BENFORD: You suck
all the fun out of it.
That's the thing.
Don't eat the cream first.
That's the usual rule
about desserts.
Yes.
The Bowl spins quite rapidly, as
you would guess, to create
an artificial gravity.
And as you'll see, in your
location the Bowl--
and all the bowl has
habitat in it.
It's not just mirrors plus a
habitat somewhere else--
you can have very
light gravity.
And therefore the species
are different.
The living conditions
And the humans in this novel get
to experience several of
these different g's.
The main equatorial section is
called the Great Plain, and
it's at 0.8g.
This sketch is in the book.
Use your own work.
LARRY NIVEN: The sketches, the
visuals, all of the visual
were done from sketches
we made by Don Davis.
We took a flat fee for doing
several paintings.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yes.
Next.
Several paintings indeed,
because this is a close up of
the Don Davis.
He's a guy I've known since
Chesley Bonestell introduced
him to me, and Don
was 18 years old,
back in the late 1960's.
Here's a close up.
You can see the mirror zone.
And you can see the storms above
both oceans and land in
the Great Plain.
And you'll see everything at
such a scale, you can't tell
anything about the inhabitants
at this range.
Which is largely true of the
Earth, except for some large
constructions.
Next.
So the--
LARRY NIVEN: In fact the thing
looks so planet-like that you
have to keep remembering, and
the protagonists have to keep
remembering, you're looking
across interplanetary scales,
objects as far away as Mars.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah but you
can tell essentially the major
characteristics over an
interplanetary distance.
And so this is a scene that
occurs fairly early in.
The way for this starship to
actually maneuver in is, first
it has to lose some velocity,
and it wants to explore the
object, so it flies up the
jet, to decelerate.
Great scene to write.
And this is a Don
Davis painting.
You'll see the larger
version in
unfortunately black and white.
Although in the e-Edition
maybe it's in color.
I actually haven't even looked
at the e-Edition.
And notice the large magnetic
coils around
the rim of the knothole.
And there's some other magnetic
features too.
There's a lot of magnetism in
this, because I've done a lot
of classical electrodynamics,
and I taught it at UC Irvine--
the advanced class.
They've got a graduate class.
To me the most important
technology of the last 200
years has clearly been
that that derives
from the Maxwell Equations.
I mean, it's made this
company, right?
I mean it's the key
technology.
And we're still mining it.
Only a few months ago, some guys
at Imperial College in
London announced an easy way
to produce a coherent
microwave emitter from a solid
by flashing light on it.
Completely a new discovery.
It's going to revolutionize
microwave transmission.
It's amazing where you don't
even have to tune.
LARRY NIVEN: And it gets
us cheap [? sugary ?]
[? cereals. ?]
GREGORY BENFORD: That's right.
Yeah that's an immediate
application.
Here's a view from standing in
the Great Plain, looking out
into the distance on
a very clear day.
This is a clear day.
It has a deep ocean, which
is held in by a
membrane at the top.
And this is the kind of view
that we imagine would be true
if you were able to stand there
and look across at and
see such great distances.
This is on a clear
day, remember.
So you see some fading with
distance but not a lot.
Next.
And here's another part
of that view.
It's all part of one painting.
You'll notice in the foreground
there's what we
call a zig-zag tree, which is
an adaptation we haven't
explained yet to this world.
There's a human walking
over toward the left.
And you can see the scale, as
the whole thing just runs away
into the distance, over
colossal distances.
It's inverse to a planet, in
that the horizon tilts up, so
you can see great distances.
But there's something
else in there.
Next slide.
Something else within
view, and it's this.
This is an animal.
It looks like a fish because
it flies through
the air, very slowly.
It's like a giant blimp.
And it's actually the
means of transport--
one of the means of transport
that the inhabitants use.
Because, guess what, there's
not going to be a climate
change problem here because
there are no fossil fuels.
You have to get around
in some other means.
You could make fuels
of course, the
way we do with ethanol.
But it's cheaper to get around,
since you've got a lot
of time, in a method that
doesn't burn something.
Because you have to be careful
of the environment.
You don't want too
much oxidation
to run out of control.
So that's some of the
environment that we have spent
a whole lot of time and
fun in designing.
The whole strategy of the first
book is to show you a
lot of things, let you reach
some assumptions, and then
undermine them and prove them
false in the second book.
That's what makes
it fun for us.
So anything more about--
this is called a sky
fish, by the way.
It's called by the humans
a sky fish.
LARRY NIVEN: You can't
pronounce the
word in Bird Folk.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah because
the Bird Folk are the people
who run this place, and they
have a lot of feathers.
And it's one of their major
modes of expression.
And they regard these curious
primates, who come on-board
and have to be, of course,
immediately grabbed and corralled.
I mean, you don't want new
influences, right?
You don't want instability in
the Bowl, because instability
means death.
But these primates have this
curious thing that--
I mean they make gestures
with their arms.
They have these funny little
facial expressions, and they
try to convey meaning
with them.
But they don't use the full
glory of a fan feather
presentation.
They can't change colors.
They can't rattle, and
rustle, and move.
I mean it just shows you
how limited they are.
Poor things.
And they have this kind
of simple starship.
Well we've seen a lot
of those before.
They come and go, you know.
It's a different attitude.
LARRY NIVEN: We've been
avoiding some
spoilers, so far.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yes and we're
going to keep avoiding
them, aren't we?
LARRY NIVEN: That was
topic I was--
I'm not going to tell them about
the Builders, right?
GREGORY BENFORD: Oh, right
LARRY NIVEN: As with
"Ringworld," you don't know
much about the Builders until
you get into the book.
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
Because it's just too damn much
to show you all of New
York in one day, right?
LARRY NIVEN: But the Builders
do go onstage quick.
They have to with a Big Smart
Object because that's who is
running everything.
Their quite obvious,
quite obtrusive.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yes.
But there's an old saying--
my father was a
professional army officer.
That's how I ended up spending
three years in occupied
Germany, three years
in occupied Japan.
And I learned things about
hierarchies, both in Japan and
in the army.
When you go into the GQ, the
General Headquarters, the
first person you meet
is not a general.
That rule applies to the Bowl.
Next slide.
Conservative means careful
because Big Smart Objects
means it's not mutually stable
like the Ringworld was
supposedly first
thought to be.
It turns out it's not
usually stable.
In fact I gave the problem of,
calculate the stability of the
Ringworld as a problem on the
qualifying exam for the PhD at
UC Irvine, one year.
And guess how many people out of
18 candidates managed to do
the calculation correctly, and
reach the right conclusion.
One?
Do I hear two?
Zero?
How many pessimists--
how many vote for zero?
Yeah, well you're right
to be skeptical.
The correct number is
two, out of 18.
They said it was one of the
toughest problems they had
ever had on an exam,
because they hadn't
seen one like it before.
And you see, I wanted to
privilege the people who had
read "Ringworld." I've never
said that in public before.
It was 1977, so they
had a chance.
OK.
BRAD TEMPLETON: Really, because
we did that one in
high school integration.
I mean just, no mass,
no gravity
inside a disc or a sphere.
We did that.
But anyway.
GREGORY BENFORD: That's right.
Yeah I mean you can do it.
It's just an interval.
LARRY NIVEN: They were using
"Ringworld" calculations at my
high school last
time I visited.
GREGORY BENFORD: You can
calculate the potential field,
and then show that the lateral
movement increases the energy,
and therefore the system
will go that way.
So that Ringworld will simply
slide into the star.
If you push it will
just keep going.
Like a ball rolling
down a hill.
LARRY NIVEN: Which is why there
are attitude jets in the
second book.
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
And so in "Bowl of Heaven"--
actually, I think I left
this out deliberately.
It'll be in the second book--
somebody says, how come they
just don't turn off
the jet and coast?
Think for a minute.
LARRY NIVEN: Bowl.
Interstellar wind.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
And the star.
Who wins?
It's a complicated
dynamics problem.
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah.
The wind stops the Bowl.
The sun, being more massive
keeps going.
You lose your sun.
Now what?
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
But it could be, if you're in a
low density region that the
sun's gravity wins.
And either way it goes,
it's unstable.
If you turn off the
jet you're dead.
The Bowl is spinning, that keeps
your orientation, but it
doesn't help you with
the instability.
And there are other
problems too.
How is this maintained?
By a complicated set of magnetic
fields, a rapidly
spinning object with electrical
charge, generates a
magnetic field.
And lots of great engineering,
which I hope will form the
basis for future qualifying
exam questions.
Well you've probably
read this one.
Is this the last?
No it's not.
Yeah.
So smart means vigilant.
You can read that.
It's more effective.
LARRY NIVEN: I didn't deal with
the problem of drilling
in the vacuum on the Ringworld,
long ago.
It's the reason you don't
find oil wells.
GREGORY BENFORD: But if you're
on the Bowl, and you drill
through, you're not only going
to be sucked through by the
vacuum, you have a velocity
relative to the rest of the
background of a hundreds
of kilometers a second.
And it's going to get you
into trouble because the
outside of the Bowl--
we have some interesting things
about this in the
second book--
the outside the Bowl is
not just bare skin.
It has constructs on it.
It's useful.
So you're almost certainly going
to run into something.
So it's going to be a very
bad idea to think about.
And they have safeguards
against that.
The point about this is to say,
why should we think about
this enormous object?
Well it's a way of thinking
about, what would intelligent
life do, if it really had a lot
of time, and a big energy
budget, and had motivations
that are not ours.
There's an old story told about
bringing an aboriginal
from Australia in the 19th
century to London.
And he looked at St. Paul's
Cathedral, and these
buildings, and these streets,
and he said, you know, this is
very impressive, but
why did you do it?
Why did you bother?
I mean, he couldn't see the
point of building large
buildings and a city.
It just didn't seem like
something he wanted to do.
Well maybe the Bowl of Heaven
will be something that we
wouldn't want to do,
but somebody did.
And who was that?
That's really the thrust
of the book.
And, oh by the way, why is it
going to Glory, the target for
the starship.
And then some other things.
As we always say toward
end, events ensue.
This is why it's fun to
write these books.
It's because it's just kind of
fun to fool around with ideas.
And from the point of view of
the guy whose published over
200 scientific papers, it is
very much like doing science,
when it's really good.
That is, you're having
new ideas.
You're working them out
in a rigorous way.
The writing, as Larry said,
is the hard part.
LARRY NIVEN: And things
keep surprising you.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yes.
That's right.
And so we keeping kicking
my ideas back and forth.
LARRY NIVEN: We've been hard at
work on the second book as
we drove around the Southern
California area.
If you can carpool, you
can collaborate.
Yeah and it's more productive
than just
listening to classic rock.
So it's a fun process.
And our intention is to finish
this subject in two books.
Now "Ringworld" has how
many books now?
LARRY NIVEN: "Ringworld"
is four, and
"Ringworld" is finished.
It was going to be one.
GREGORY BENFORD: Until
further notice, then.
LARRY NIVEN: This one, we
planned two, and we're still
planning two.
It's not going to be one of
those seven-part trilogies.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yes.
Or even a three-part trilogy
because trilogies--
the classic problem with
trilogies is the
middle book, right?
How to eliminate this problem,
make it two books.
Seems simple.
So, why don't we do Q&A?
But it actually announces part
of the narrative strategy of
telling such stories.
So we thought what's
the opposite?
LARRY NIVEN: It's
a critic's term.
It's a critics who was not
impressed by a flood of Big
Dumb Object stories.
"Ringworld" followed by
"Orbitsville," and the
"Rendezvous with Rama,"
and several others.
GREGORY BENFORD: And
Farley's books--
He wrote a Big Dumb Object
trilogy, which is the only
part of his work which is out
of print, he told me.
LARRY NIVEN: Well, he broke
too many physics
laws with that one.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah,
that's true.
LARRY NIVEN: And bent
probability a lot too far.
BRAD TEMPLETON: Wait a minute,
are you talking about "Titan?"
LARRY NIVEN: Yes.
BRAD TEMPLETON: That
wasn't dumb.
LARRY NIVEN: Wasn't it?
No, you're right.
Someone was in charge.
GREGORY BENFORD: Oh there was
somebody charge, yes.
That's true.
But it tended, like most ideas
in science fiction, to have a
half-life of roughly a decade,
and then to go away.
So now it's back.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
It's great fun to
have you here.
How are the inhabitants
protected
against ionizing radiation?
LARRY NIVEN: Lots of atmosphere,
for one thing.
And for another, that sun is a
wretched little red dwarf.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
LARRY NIVEN: You've got the
flare, but it's generating
mostly heat.
Check me out on this, because
you're the expert.
GREGORY BENFORD: That's
true. , No, I mean,
about what you said.
LARRY NIVEN: OK.
GREGORY BENFORD: But it's
also the magnetic field.
LARRY NIVEN: Hundreds of
kilometers of atmosphere being
held in by what is essentially
the far future descendants of
a sandwich baggie.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yes.
Right.
But the whole region is
magnetically dominated, and so
you fend off an lot
of cosmic rays.
LARRY NIVEN: Flare
is confined.
If you fiddle with the flare,
you're going to get ionizing
radiation where you
don't want it.
Something to remember.
GREGORY BENFORD: That's right.
The trick in the system is that
the jet is very dangerous.
And it will always
work perfectly,
until the second book.
AUDIENCE: So you said the Bowl's
going somewhere, and
you said it's hard to stop.
LARRY NIVEN: The Bowl is a
spacecraft and it's been
traveling for a long time.
It's visited many,
many places.
AUDIENCE: Well, anyway, you said
it would be very hard to
stop, or I assume, even turn,
and get into an orbit.
So what the heck's going
to happen about that?
LARRY NIVEN: There's lots
of space out there.
Light years are big.
You don't need to make
a hairpin turn.
And if you did, you could
do it around the sun.
AUDIENCE: But even an
infinitesimal turn would, I
assume, give you the same
problems you described with
turning off the jet.
GREGORY BENFORD: Well, remember
you could apply
torque over a very long time.
Yes, as he said, you could
make the turns slowly.
It has to.
The knothole is only so big.
But, 747's don't make
house calls.
You fly by, you've got time,
you send faster ships, you
explore the region, and
then, you keep going.
LARRY NIVEN: And launching a
spaceship is fairly easy.
You just drop it off
the edge, at around
600 miles per second.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A pivot from plot
to business, for a
moment, if you would.
I'd be interested in your two
perspectives as authors on the
changes in the publishing
industry,
specifically related to--
I don't know about the rest of
you, but I don't buy many of
these in paper form anymore,
and I'd be interested in
seeing how this looks from
your side of the pen.
LARRY NIVEN: I carry a Kindle.
BRAD TEMPLETON: Can you get
Play Store on the Kindle?
GREGORY BENFORD: I don't
waste time either.
LARRY NIVEN: I got my Kindle
free from Jeff Bezos, at a
three-day party he threw for
around 40 of the people, and
their wives and husbands,
whom he wanted to meet.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah.
And the Kindle was signed.
That's another thing about
collectors, is they want the
print edition, you know,
information stored in the
bodies of dead trees, because
you can get them signed.
There are ways around that.
I mean David Brin and I reissued
a novel of ours,
"Heart of the Comet," and we
give away a card that we have
signed that is that card "Heart
of the Comet." You can
keep it on your file if you
want, but otherwise it's an
electronic edition.
Although there is a
Print on Demand.
But what you're talking about is
the big war that's going on
in publishing.
And at the moment it's really
like the opening chapters of
World War II.
It's all offense, no defense.
We were just doing a signing
on the Queen Mary, Saturday
night for the Independent
Booksellers of Southern
California, their
annual meeting.
And there were several speeches
at the banquet about--
well they were Amazon
hate sessions.
Right?
I mean it was like a
scene from 1984.
Everybody chants about
Big Brother.
And at the same time New York
publishing was getting
hollered out.
You can tell it by the growing
incompetence of the staff who
had been recently hired, when
they fired the executives.
No one seems to understand that
up ahead in the future,
there's some kind
of equilibrium
we're going to approach.
And no one seems to be really
thinking forward about that
equilibrium now.
Barnes and Noble is tottering
and may collapse, the last big
chain that's across
the continent.
The independents are finding
niche markets, such as a Books
Inc, one of my favorite
bookstores, is actually a
chain about, what, seven
or eight stores.
Very good store.
And they make a point of being
up on everything and knowing
what's going on.
You walk into a store, they got
the book you heard about
today on NPR, or read in
the "New York Times."
But how does this all work?
I don't know, except the writers
are actually, I think,
in many ways the biggest
beneficiaries, because we now
have options.
We can control our work.
I am reissuing my novels
selectively.
Although I know I could get
publishers to reissue them, I
can reissue them myself.
I can hire the artist.
I hired a copywriter--
a copy editor.
I've got a promotional
editor I use.
Even to revisit novels I've
written before and prune them
up, and change, or readjust
the physics.
I care about that
kind of thing.
I'm working on a novel of mine
from the from the aughts,
"Cosm," which is actually
set at UCI.
And it was a nice chance to
satirize other members of my
department.
Some of whom, luckily,
are dead.
BRAD TEMPLETON: Coincedence?
GREGORY BENFORD: Some say not.
So we can choose our markets.
We could choose to do print on
demand, or just e-Edition.
I've done both.
Larry's starting to reissue
his books in this way.
The point is, the books are
going to be always available,
at least in digital form,
or print on demand.
That's a whole new landscape
for a writer.
And for this first time
in my career--
our career--
there's a sense of real opening
for the writers.
And you may not think about it
right away, but there's the
publishers, and the bookstores,
and all that, But
they wouldn't have a business
without us.
And we're getting some control
of how we want
the fields to work.
And that's a good feeling.
LARRY NIVEN: For your sense of
proportion, my first novel, I
had to settle for
4% royalties.
GREGORY BENFORD: God.
Really?
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah.
GREGORY BENFORD: "World
of Ptavvs"?
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah, well
I was a novice.
4% royalties.
My agent later argued them into
a bigger proportion, but
most people get 10%
or 8% royalties.
And you get that after you've
been in the field two or three
books deep.
HG Wells used to get 25%,
an amazing figure.
He got that, I presume,
because he put
some money into it.
He was part of the backing,
of the backer.
I'm getting--
my agent is putting out my books
as the contracts lapse,
and one by one they're going
into electronic print, for
which I get 85%.
My agent keeps the 15%
she's entitled to.
This is an amazing change.
GREGORY BENFORD: It feels great
to do something better
than HG Wells.
LARRY NIVEN: Absolutely
GREGORY BENFORD: So, to conclude
on that, it's a time
of the greatest change since
that guy named Gutenberg.
And it will mean an enormous
amount particularly to the
vast majority of humanity
that has never really
had access to books.
I've been to India a lot, and
Africa, and believe me, these
are people who are starved for
information, and have been so
for thousands of years.
Can you imagine the civilization
that was
information starved forever?
Well read the history books.
That's most of human history.
This is really going
to alter humanity.
And I, with my biases, think,
look, I come from a small town
in southern Alabama.
Information starved?
I know what we're
talking about.
I went to-- my brother and I--
I'm an identical twin--
went to a one room schoolhouse
when we were growing up, in a
farm community.
It changes your view
of the world.
LARRY NIVEN: That it does.
AUDIENCE: So our species used
to build things, that-- you
know we have ruins from
millennia ago, and now you're
in front of a room full of
people who routinely get woken
up in the middle of the
night because our
system needs our help.
So I'm wondering if you see sort
of a broad societal trend
towards building smarter
objects that need more
maintenance.
LARRY NIVEN: Smarter objects
that need more maintenance?
Obama would support that.
Jobs.
GREGORY BENFORD: You
mean Steve, or--
LARRY NIVEN: No, I mean jobs.
GREGORY BENFORD: That is an
interesting way to look at it.
But the reason is, of course,
that builds a
society of smart people.
I mean people who can manage
a complex system.
If you're building the pyramids,
a Big Dumb Object,
you don't need literate
people.
So it's easy to be impressed
by gargantuan things.
But Gargantuan Smart Things is
qualitatively different.
I wrote a whole book, which in
fact I'm going to bring back
in print within a year or so,
called "Deep Time." The
subtitle was "How Humanity
Communicates Across
Millennia." It's nonfiction
about my experience of trying
to design long-term messages
in various places, like the
nuclear waste facility in New
Mexico, and the Cassini
mission to Saturn.
And one of the things I learned,
to my astonishment,
is that there were many museums,
and art galleries,
and libraries in the
ancient world.
Guess how many survived the
collapse of the Roman Empire,
or other empires?
Zero.
Parts of them were left over.
None of the institutions
survived.
So, if you really want a
long-term message, in the
ancient past anyway, you should
invest in granite.
Carve it deep and leave
it in a desert.
AUDIENCE: I'm a big
"Ringworld" fan.
And recently computer graphics
imaging has, I think, made it
possible to actually make
movies out of this.
Not that it might fit in two
or three hours, but I just
wondered what you thought
of those kinds of ideas.
And, I think, in general the
idea of books are wonderful
because you don't need any
computer graphics imaging.
You can think of it
in your mind.
But now we have the technology
to do all these kinds of
movies, and are we making
readers dumber by making these
movies with big explosions?
LARRY NIVEN: Are we making
readers dumber by showing so
much in a movie?
GREGORY BENFORD: Well we're
making moviegoers dumber.
But tell them about the
"Ringworld" movie.
LARRY NIVEN: The "Ringworld"
movie has suffered over the
decades because I signed some
papers I shouldn't have early
in my career.
But we renegotiated a contract
a couple years ago and now
that the guy who has the right
to has shopped it to MGM.
That's all I know.
The movie is at MGM.
And if [? Mandel ?]
fails to come through
with it, I get a
chance to make a movie.
But that won't happen
for a little while.
GREGORY BENFORD: But everything
you say about
special effects is quite so.
AUDIENCE: You don't really
need actors anymore.
GREGORY BENFORD: No, and you
don't even need a big budget.
Remember the movie "Moon" made
by the son of a famous rock
star for, what was
it, a million?
It was some small sum, and it
made tens of millions, because
there was a good script.
And it was a smart script.
And the special effects
were cheap.
LARRY NIVEN: I'm remembering
"Tom Corbett, Space Cadet."
when you had to imagine
most of what you were
supposed to be seeing.
GREGORY BENFORD: Hell,
you had to imagine
what you were seeing.
I mean, rocket ships,
in which the exhaust
rises, as it goes across.
Yeah, well.
I mean, it never occurred to
them, apparently, to turn the
camera sideways and just have
a rocket ship come down like
this, so the exhaust would
appear to be going away from
the rocket.
LARRY NIVEN: Do you know how
they got freefall in "2001: A
Space Odyssey"?
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah they
spun the giant hoop.
LARRY NIVEN: They put the
astronaut on a line, and then
shot him from underneath so
that the line didn't show.
Now he's in freefall.
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
And it was remarkably
convincing.
It really was.
Arthur Clarke gave me a
photograph of him walking
through that rotating drum that
they use for the interior
of the spaceship.
Do you know the famous
establishing shot where the
guy appears to run
over the ceiling?
And he did the same thing.
He said there's a film of him
doing the same thing.
But I haven't seen it.
But it was funny to see him in
this futuristic context, which
now lies in the past, "2001."
AUDIENCE: I like the way they
did the special effects for
"Apollo 13" to get
the zero gravity.
Back to something
you just said.
So on the one hand, we have
electronic books, which means
you can reissue things, you can
publish things, you make
more money with it, which I
think is wonderful by the way.
The downside is, something that
you just said, if you
want it to last, put
it in granite.
One of the reasons I don't buy
electronic books is I don't
want Amazon deciding that, for
some reason, I didn't buy
their electronic book, after
I've already got it.
You know, I want to keep it.
I want to have my own backup,
and my own copies.
GREGORY BENFORD:
Well, buy both.
AUDIENCE: Well, it
it's in print.
But again, if it's in print,
or if it's only
in electronic form.
I can go to the used bookstore,
and look forever,
and maybe find it,
and maybe not.
Where do you stand on that sort
of DRM restrictions--
you know, high price, low price,
and mass distribution--
kind of thing?
LARRY NIVEN: I like
cheaper books.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, me too.
GREGORY BENFORD: Except ours.
AUDIENCE: If you keep it up,
everybody buys them, right?
So, it's kind of a tradeoff.
LARRY NIVEN: I want
my ideas spread.
I don't even mind pirates
very much.
I mind them some.
GREGORY BENFORD: True.
What you bring up is
a serious issue.
First, I'm against DRM.
Second, if you really want to
keep your electronic books
safe and preserved forever,
well you could put them in
orbit where I don't think
they can reach them.
But it's always good
to have a backup.
I mean, that's what I tell
people when they say, what is
it like to be an
identical twin.
I say, have a backup.
So I too like physical books.
And I have a few electronic
books but I don't
mostly read that way.
But they're crowding me
out of my houses,
so there's the downside.
LARRY NIVEN: Me too.
If you can't bear to throw away
a book, you're in trouble
eventually.
They pile up.
GREGORY BENFORD: And
thank you for it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GREGORY BENFORD: Oh great.
BRAD TEMPLETON: Oh, there
are books I've
wanted to throw away.
GREGORY BENFORD: Well, you know,
as a conservationist,
you could burn them for heat.
Which further has a benefit that
other people will not be
troubled by reading.
BRAD TEMPLETON: So, you've
touched on this a little bit,
but I was wondering if you might
want to talk a little
bit more about collaboration.
I mean, I think, Larry, you're
becoming known as a great
collaborator.
Once, when I was angry at Jerry
Pournelle, I told him,
you know Jerry, you write really
good books when you
work with Larry.
So.
GREGORY BENFORD: And he said?
LARRY NIVEN: I think he
was flattered, myself.
I write really good books
when I write with Jerry.
BRAD TEMPLETON: No,
you do actually.
I think the two of you together
do stuff that you
don't do on your own.
So tell me what is about the
collaborative process that
makes that happen.
LARRY NIVEN: You learn each
other's strengths.
Jerry's, for instance, are with
military and politics.
Mine are with aliens, and
characters who go crazy.
GREGORY BENFORD: Yeah,
that's true.
Crazy characters.
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah.
When a heroic character is
wading his way through a sea
of troubles, fighting his way
toward a goal, that's Jerry.
The character goes
nuts, that's me.
GREGORY BENFORD: It says so
much about your lives.
LARRY NIVEN: Collaborations
are more fun, and more
friendly, than sitting at your
typewriter all alone writing.
Of course, as a collaborator
you're going to do a lot of
that anyway, because you don't
live together in the same
house unless you're
man and wife.
Jerry and I live about 25
minutes away from each other.
Greg lives an hour and a
half away, maybe two.
But we've got the internet.
When we didn't have the
internet, Jerry lived a little
closer and it was easier, but
we still had to carry texts
back and forth.
BRAD TEMPLETON: What, are you
saying as soon as he got the
internet, he moved further
away from you?
LARRY NIVEN: You got the
right idea, but I
was the one who moved.
GREGORY BENFORD: Right.
To a bigger house.
Bigger still.
LARRY NIVEN: Yeah.
The books were piling up.
We had to move to
a bigger house.
GREGORY BENFORD: You're
quite right.
We have different strengths.
You know, physicist He's
an alien tech--
He's an alien.
LARRY NIVEN: Greg has got the
electromagnetic fields that I
don't know very much about it.
GREGORY BENFORD: But it's also
true that writing is a lonely
business, and you can
advance your ideas
faster by speaking them.
We all know that.
And kicking ideas back and forth
generates new ideas at a
much, much faster rate than
sitting there staring at a a
cathode ray tube.
Or a stream of some kind.
It's just one of the strengths
of human beings.
We are a collaborative
species.
Right?
That's why we talk so much.
LARRY NIVEN: I do not have the
patience to be a scientist.
I knew that fairly early.
GREGORY BENFORD: And there's
a deeper thing here.
Modern science fiction, by the
way, which invented fandom--
the word and the thing itself,
and fanzines, and all that--
came out of the scientific,
technical culture.
It has always been marked by a
high degree of collaboration.
And that is true in
the scientific
and engineering culture.
This is not true in the
literary culture.
Collaborations are rare.
It's because they come
out of an older,
and different culture.
Scientists inherently
collaborate.
By far, the majority of all
scientific papers are
collaborations.
A high fraction of SF work
is collaboration.
A minority, but far higher
than in other fields.
Even in mysteries, there are
very few collaborations.
Westerns, romance novels--
they're almost all individual
writers.
Not so, in science fiction.
And so it underlies the fact
that science fiction is a
cultural expression
of the dominant
force in modern times--
science and technology.
Try to imagine the last two
centuries without science and
technology, and its
rate of change.
Actually try to imagine the last
two centuries without the
United States of America, but
that's another discussion.
So you ought to realize this
is actually part of a very
much larger phenomena that
is taking over the world.
We have many competitors
in Asia, and so forth.
They're copying our methods.
Some years ago, at the World
Science Fiction Convention in
Tokyo, I spoke to the team of
six editors from the Chinese
science fiction magazine.
We've never had a science
fiction magazine, and they had
six editors.
It's a monthly.
It has circulation of about a
third to a half a million
copies, whereas "Analog" sells
about 35,000 a month.
And the Chinese government
supports this magazine--
subsidizes it-- because they
want to invert the process.
You see, the first science
fiction magazine was "Amazing
Stories" published by a group
of radio magazines.
And it was the anomaly
inside there.
And it's the only one that
anyone remembers now.
The Chinese want to draw their
own people into the culture of
science and technology and the
habits of mind, by using
science fiction.
They're inverting--
reverse engineering--
what we did naturally and
spontaneously in the 20th century.
So this has been an important
phenomena
going around the world.
And it's the reason there
are now science fiction
conventions in India, and other
seemingly unlikely places.
Africa, even.
And it's part of the shaping of
human culture that is being
done by you, the technological
elite.
BRAD TEMPLETON: So I
think we're running
close to the end.
I'll ask one last question,
actually, because you two are
both well-known for being
specialists in hard science
fiction, by which I like to call
realistic science fiction
that actually follows
the physics.
And now it's not just necessary
to follow physics.
I often say romance novels have
excellent physics, and
they barely violate
those laws.
They may violate the laws
of chemistry, but
not the laws of physics.
GREGORY BENFORD:
And of biology.
BRAD TEMPLETON: But what is it
that you feel is the great
virtue of hard science
fiction?
What is it that makes-- when you
sit down to write, why do
you feel that that's what
you must write?
LARRY NIVEN: I'm not a fanatic
on the subject.
I have written science
fiction.
I've written fantasy.
I have written detective
fiction.
When I get up the nerve, I
write detective science
fiction, and I've got to tell
you, it's the hardest work.
I generally write science
fiction because that's where
my ideas come from.
I've got no contempt for every
other field of fiction.
They will all teach you
to read, and reading
teaches you to think.
There was a phenomenon
called Laser Books.
Laser Books was going to be
science fiction, as produced
by a house that produced
mostly romance--
well, all romance novels.
They were going to branch out,
going to be science fiction,
going to be the label that
sells, rather than the
author's name.
This, as far as I was concerned,
was a great way to
train readers to read, and
eventually they would grow up
and read my stuff.
As it turned out, the name
was what sold anyway.
And I do mean the name
of the author.
Robert Gleason, my favorite
editor, told me that he was--
he tends to travel among the
people who transport the books
to the stores, the
distributors.
He told me he was at a bar where
they were gathered, and
from the next table he hears,
there's only one Laser Book
that sells at all well, and
it's by one author.
And his name [INAUDIBLE]
It turned out to be Jerry
Pournelle's Laser books were
the only ones who sold
well, among Laser.
And Laser bowed out gracefully,
returned all
rights, got out of the field,
and it was one of those happy
stories, as far as people who
think that the author's name
ought to be what sells
books best.
BRAD TEMPLETON: All right, well,
on that note I'd like to
thank our two guests for a
fabulous presentation.
[APPLAUSE]